okay i'm going to start with our um
criticism of the criticizer
there was a fellow who criticized the
scientific method can you believe that
criticizing the scientific method
what arguments could he possibly have
well here it is let me uh put him on and
i think he was hi
uh we have um this person he said
that you need to test
explanations before he said we have to
test hypothesis which are assumptions
you know and now he's gonna he's saying
his argument is you also need to test
explanations okay so here it goes give
me a second here here goes
this follow claims that in science in
his version of science you must test the
explanation before it can become
scientific
you have to test these explanations and
if you can't test these explanations
well then you're not doing science
okay
so he says we have to test the
explanations
what could he possibly be talking about
i mean you know um like i said he talked
last time the previous time he said uh
talk about
you have to test the hypothesis a
hypothesis is an assumption you know so
we make an assumption like you might
make an assumption in quantum mechanics
saying that light is mediated by
particles
okay you can make that assumption how
are you going to test that
okay
uh you know you can't test it
and test an explanation well even if you
test it all you're doing is convincing
yourself or convincing someone else that
your theory is correct
that's what he's talking about okay and
here here's the rundown can you give me
a second here
okay test the hypothesis is to test an
assumption we don't test assumptions we
accept them at face value in order to
understand the theory the explanation
found it upon those assumptions
that's the explanation well you know
what are you doing uh you're just trying
to convince someone okay you're uh what
are you gonna do run an experiment or
what okay
what do you want me to do to test the
explanation
especially on something that is
invisible and intangible such as the
mediator of gravity what are you gonna
test you're gonna run an experiment to
test you know my magic wand here you
know tell us what's up here what's down
here
what invisible thing is pulling what
invisible thing is pushing
intangible and invisible
i mean it doesn't make any sense to say
you're gonna test the theory
theory is one that you listen to you
understand it
so you know just to comprehend it that's
it there's no more than that in science
uh someone might say i may have an
assumption saying god okay so the
individual introduces god and then he
says my theory is that god created the
universe and so he goes on and he says
yeah god moved his magic wand said voila
and there was the universe great that's
a theory that's what he believes and
this is how he visualizes the origin of
the universe okay
and so when you look at that you say
okay that's his theory okay now you can
criticize his assumption you can
criticize his theory but test it how are
you gonna test that god is out there i
mean what experiment do you propose
it doesn't make any sense so yeah to
test a theory as he said all you're
doing is actually
focusing on religion unbelief what
you're doing is you know persuading
convincing converting and recruiting
that's the elements that you're
considering when you're talking about uh
testing and explanation
and that's what the prosecutor does with
the jury he tries to convince the jurors
okay to his side of the case
and uh that's also what a priest does
you know what does he do he talks about
to come up whatever and what is he doing
he's trying to convince the flock
that's it you know so
you know so yeah experiment uh trial and
error uh that's technology we don't do
experiments to test
either the hypothesis or the theory you
can run whatever experiment you want at
home no problem you know go ahead and
run your experiment do whatever you have
to stand on your head if you need to but
when you come to the um
to the conference
we want you to tell us what you learned
tell us a mechanism that we can use in
physics okay and so you say this is how
i think gravity works or this is how i
think electricity works great and you
tell your theory
and you know people might have questions
might attack it might defend it whatever
but the issue here is the attacking and
defending the saying it's correct and
correct true or false that's belief
that's got to do with opinions
religion
uh the theory is just what it is
objectively you just try to understand
it to see what the guy has going through
his mind